the San Francisco Airport has officially
banned plastic water bottles in a city
teeming with human feces and used
syringes hydration for travelers is
officially a bridge too far
ironically a number of studies show the
ever multiplying environmental
regulations not only don't help the
environment but they actually hurt the
environment we will examine the real
purpose behind the rules then Joe Biden
releases his first televised campaign ad
in the title is absolutely hilarious and
completely oblivious we'll get to that
finally a new study published in an
influential journal may have just
confirmed 75 years of kooky cranky
far-right conspiracy theories all that
and more I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
what a show today thank goodness I have
my reusable leftist tears tumbler
otherwise I think the police would come
in and arrest me I think would be a
capital offense if I had a reusable
water bottle here but the leftist tears
tumbler is there to protect you at all
times from the floods of left us tears
and from the increasing environmental
regulations we'll get to these nonsense
regulations and what they really mean
because they are certainly not about
protecting the environment but first let
me tell you why I feel so good why I
wake up so refreshed and that would be
bowline branch bowline branch sheets
everything they make from bedding to
blankets is made from pure 100% organic
cotton that means they start out super
soft and they get even softer over time
and what you do is you buy directly from
them so that you're essentially paying
wholesale prices one of the perks of my
job is that on occasion on a handful of
times I've gotten to stay at really
really nice hotels when I pay for my own
hotels I'm usually at the one on the
side of the highway that costs 20 bucks
a night but on occasion I've gotten to
stay at some really really nice ones and
one of the the best aspects of the
really nice hotels is the bedding you
just feel so great you can really feel
the difference first time I slept on
when I thought I need to get these
sheets when you try to buy luxury sheets
they can cost up to $1,000 in the store
so obviously not gonna do that but
Boleyn brand sheets are only a couple
hundred bucks the way they do it is they
cut out the middleman they can go
straight to you and they are absolutely
incredible I love my Bolin brand sheets
I give them out to his gifts to my
friends and family I really really
believe in this product I love them if
you want to get me a present
I don't know Christmas is coming up in
like what five or six months bolon
branches a wonderful way to do it
shipping is free you can try them for 30
nights if you don't love them send them
back for a refund you're not gonna want
to send them back I'm promising you that
there is no risk no reason to not give
them a try you can get started right now
right now my listeners get $50 off your
first set of sheets don't say I never
did nothing for you that's a pretty good
deal go to Boland branch com promo code
Michael go to B oh L L and branch
komm promo code michael mi CH AE l
that's the only way to get your fifty
bucks off your first set of sheets
Boland branch comm promo code Michael we
have got to talk about something that's
not as comfortable that's not as
convenient that's not as luxurious and
that is all these stupid environmental
regulations that are coming out San
Francisco Airport has officially banned
plastic water bottles that's the great
scourge this is the great political
issue of our day not open borders
immigration economic turmoil trade war
IP theft no no no the big issue is
plastic water bottles this new
regulation comes three years after
California banned single-use plastic
grocery bags thank goodness we got rid
of that though the earth was hurtling
toward Armageddon but then we got rid of
single-use plastic grocery bags and
finally the earth was saved this of
course all comes at the same time that
we cannot get plastic drinking straws
any longer we've gotten rid of the
plastic drinking straws our civilization
will be saved
you can shoot heroin in the streets of
San Francisco outside of an elementary
school and the government will give you
free needles but if you sip your iced
coffee out of a plastic drinking straw
that is nearly a capital offense I think
I think they're increasing the severity
of that crime this plastic water bottle
ban is incredibly stupid and it's not
just stupid because it won't have that
much of an impact it's it's stupid
because the purpose isn't to help the
environment the purpose is just to harm
you like all of these other regulations
and bans it's not about the environment
it's about inconveniencing you here's
how you know by the way in San Francisco
Airport now the ban is only affecting
water bottles but you know you go into
the store at the airport or any deli or
any convenience store they don't just
sell water
bottles they sell soda bottles iced tea
bottles Gatorade juice drinks all these
different kinds of drinks all of those
are fine at San Francisco Airport the
only one you can't get is a water bottle
why is it because travel dehydrates you
I've learned this the hard way one time
I flew to New York for a bachelor party
so it's already a little dehydrated I
get on the airplane I forgot that Travel
dehydrates you I felt like I was in the
middle of the Sahara Desert men lose up
to half a gallon of water from their
bodies during a 10-hour flight it's a
lot of water and and you are also not
allowed to bring any liquid past
security in airports so what are you
supposed to do now you're supposed to
suffer that's it I guess you could bring
I don't know a metallic water bottle or
a reusable water bottle that's empty
through security and then go to the one
water fountain somewhere in the airport
or you can go into the airport bathroom
and fill up your water bottle that
doesn't that sound delicious doesn't
that sound really appetizing or you can
suffer and that's what they want you to
do they want you to suffer the whole
point of this is inconvenience you saw
this with the plastic grocery bag ban so
three years ago in California other
states have followed suit but in 2016 in
California they banned single-use
plastic grocery bags New York followed
California this past March and when they
did that New York's Governor Andrew
Cuomo he declared that the ban would
quote help reduce the litter in our
communities protect our water and create
a cleaner and greener New York for all
so that's what happened right that's
obviously what happened
no actually of course not plastic
pollution got significantly worse we
haven't seen the effect in New York yet
because it just happened but in
California the ban actually caused more
plastic pollution how did it do that how
do we know that there was a study out of
the University of Sydney that showed
that the ban on the single-use little
thin nothing plastic grocery bags led to
a massive increase in the sale of
thicker more environmentally damaging
plastic garbage bags so you know the
kind you line your your garbage with at
home
how's that work what what is the
relationship between grocery bags and
garbage bags that none of these
economists or none of these regulators
or none of these environmental activists
could have thought of well you know from
your own use back in the good old days
when we had plastic grocery bags you
would go you'd get all your groceries
and then you'd save your your plastic
grocery bags right and if you're
anything like my family you'd save like
300 of them you'd never use as many as
you actually got so you just have them
in a pantry somewhere but you would use
them you would slowly use them in a way
you would use them is to line your small
little garbage garbages your little
trash bins and that way is very easy was
it was actually an organic way to
recycle because you got these bags you
don't want to go out and buy new garbage
bags there's no reason to do that so you
figure okay make use with that throw
your trash away put that in the trash
throw it out you're good to go
now that you can't do that now that
those bags don't exist people have to
line their trash bins somehow so they're
going out there by much more
environmentally damaging bags okay well
at least it's better as far as the
grocery bags themselves are concerned
right wrong another study showed that
paper bags which is what replaced the
single-use plastic bags are actually
worse for the environment than the
single-use plastic bags how do we know
that Britain's environmental agencies
showed in 2011 that far back eight years
ago that you would have to reuse a paper
bag a paper grocery bag three times if
you wanted to bring its environmental
impact down to the level of a single-use
plastic bag now do you ever reuse paper
bags no nobody does you just throw them
out ironically you do reuse the
environmentally pretty fine plastic bags
but you don't reuse the paper bag so
they're actually much worse for the
environment why is that it takes a lot
more energy to make the paper bags you
have to create the pulp you have to
manufacture the paper bag and in all of
that energy and all of that time you
could have just made that single-use
very thin plastic bag from oil okay then
okay then Michael you conservative you
anti environmentalist then forget the
plastic bags forget
the paper bags I know I know the way
that we can save the environment right
this is what all the activists tell you
it's what at the grocery store check out
what they tell you you can buy one of
those reusable cotton bags
you ever see the oh those are great bags
right that's the best that's when you
really want to protect the planet from
global warming you buy those bags all
the most liberal people you know have
those bags they bring them back and
forth that's better for the environment
right no that's the worst for the
environment of all ha ha ha a headline
from courts came at just this past April
quote your cotton tote is pretty much
the worst replacement for a plastic bag
don't take my word for it listen to the
scientists 2018 study from Denmark's
Ministry of Environment and food found
that cotton shopping bags need to be
reused how many times you want to guess
so if you want you if you want to bring
the paper bag down to the environmental
impact level of a plastic bag you got to
reuse it three times you how many times
you got to reuse a cotton shopping bag
20,000 times you I'm not going to go to
the grocery store 20,000 times in my
life I go like twice a year anyway but
you're not going to do it and really
what people do is they buy the bags and
they use them one or two times and they
forget about them and then they lose
them somewhere and then you buy another
bag so now you're up to 40,000 times I
mean I mean how many times you're gonna
repeat repeat that cycle you're gonna
have to reuse these bags like 200,000
times before you can bring the
environmental impact down to a single
plastic bag this was the worst option so
what did this study out of Denmark find
what is the best way to protect the
environment in your grocery shopping
endeavors the good old plastic grocery
bag now okay maybe the environmentalists
just got it wrong they look the road to
hell is paved with good intentions sure
enough now they've seen the error of
their ways have the environmentalists
changed their tune are they saying oh
gosh we got to ban those cotton bags so
let's bring back those plastic bags no
of course not because it's not about
protecting the environment it's just
about inconveniencing you this is a big
difference between conservationism and
environmentalism conservation Teddy
Roosevelt loved conservation right a lot
of conservatives love conservation it's
where we protect the natural environment
because we like it we like the beautiful
landscapes we like the beer we want to
protect all the deer so that we can go
out and hunt and kill the deer and then
eat the deer we like the environment for
our pleasure environmentalism flips that
calculus and in environmentalism it is
no longer the idea that we're preserving
the environment for our benefit it's
that we are serving the environment we
are wicked awful terrible polluters and
the environment is this beautiful quasi
divine deity I guess this quasi divine
being and we need to serve the
environment we need to save the earth as
though the earth could be saved what
what what does that even mean this
religion of environmentalism has taken
the place of traditional religion it
offers all the elements of religion it
offers sin and pollution it offers
atonement in recycling
it offers Armageddon in global warming
which is going to kill us in 14 months
or 12 months or 10 months or 12 years or
35 years or whatever it is now it even
offers the sale of indulgences in the
form of carbon tax credits it is a
religious system everybody's got to
serve somebody and as traditional
religious observance has waned
environmentalism among other leftist
ideologies has arisen up to fill that
void you see this perhaps most clearly
not even just in the United States with
the plastic water bans in in San
Francisco Airport look over in the
United Kingdom two big stories out of
the United Kingdom a 34 year old mother
of three put her recycling in the wrong
color bag so you know here we have black
bags for trash or white bags for trash
and then we have blue bags for recycling
yes they have the same in the UK and she
went to
Borough Council to get the correct bags
to be used for recycling and they didn't
give her the bags so then she got
permission to use the black bag which is
usually for trash for her recycling so
she's still recycling she's still
separating it putting her recycling out
there do you know what happened to this
poor woman she was arrested and thrown
in jail for still recycling but not
recycling in the correct color bag how
did they catch her they they found her
on a closed-circuit TV camera putting
out the wrong color bag on the day for
the recycling so they arrested her and
threw her in jail the color of the bags
in no way affects the environment right
of course not but it does affect the
moral dictates of the Church of
environmentalism also in the UK
completely on the other side of this the
country's most prominent environmental
activists Prince Harry and Megan Markel
just flew on a private jet to stay with
their good friend Elton John in Nice
this was their fourth trip on a private
jet in 11 days fine I don't care they
can fly on as many private jets as they
want except at the exact same time just
last month Harry and Megan posted on
Instagram about how important it is to
protect the environment this this is the
the post quote as a continuation of our
monthly social awareness approach to
shine a light on the accounts that are
working toward positive change for the
month of July we turn our attention to
the environment there is a ticking clock
to protect our environment with climate
change the deterioration of our natural
resources endangerment of sacred
wildlife sacred what like we're
worshipping the wildlife what does that
even mean
the impact of plastics and micro
plastics and fossil fuel emmissions you
know like the sort that are emitted from
private jets the post goes on we are
jeopardizing this beautiful place we
call home for ourselves and for future
generations let's save it let's do our
part
ok now you could say it was just some
staffer at the palace posting man
Harry and Megan didn't post that they
don't they're not really that intense
about the environmental thing they're
not really being hypocrites they're
they're just caught up in in the royal
family no no it goes on the Duke of
Sussex Prince Harry gives a quote quote
environmental damage has been treated as
a necessary byproduct of economic growth
so deeply ingrained is this thinking
that it has been considered part of the
natural order that humankind's
development comes at the expense of our
planet only now are we starting to
notice and understand the damage that
we've been causing with nearly seven
point seven billion people inhabit in
this earth every choice every footprint
every action makes a difference please
visit the accounts were following this
month to figure out how you can create
change and help save our planet we can
only do this together and every little
bit helps every little bit helps every
footprint every action makes a
difference except for private jets four
times in 11 days economic growth is the
problem you see economic growth is not
worth environmental degradation a trip
to uncle Elton's house in Nice that is
worth environmental degradation but not
economic growth because economic growth
just effects like all those poor people
all those common people it it doesn't
look as good on an Instagram post when
you're the Prince this is religious
hypocrisy this is the same as any other
sort of religious hypocrisy the guy who
sits in the front pew at church on
Sunday and then he spends Monday through
Saturday boozing and gambling and
womanizing and lying and cheating it's
an it's not just failing to live up to
one's own standards which we all do we
all fail to live up to our standards
that's not an argument against having
standards it's not just like Prince
Harry and Megan Merkel and these other
leftist environmentalists who take
private jets everywhere you know Leo
DiCaprio or somebody it's not just that
they're failing to live up to their own
standards it's not just that they're
failing to live according to their
ideology they're just ignoring their
ideology they just do it they just fly
private four times in 11 days they don't
really believe what they're saying
they're just pretending to believe it to
conform to what has become the new
secular moral order
a big part of witches environmentalism
they want you to pretend to care about
nature and then not do anything to
protect it but you got to pretend
because we need a moral order and in a
secular atheistic society
environmentalism is going to fill that
gap I think you should do the opposite
of that I think you should stop virtuous
signaling on the environment I think you
should not Yammer on about the
environment and post about it on
Instagram and then you should protect
the natural environment because it's
nice and I like beautiful things and by
the way if you want to protect the
natural environment when you're picking
out your grocery bag save the earth
don't recycle we got to get on to 2020
2020 is I've got to move away from the
environment I'm getting too wrapped up
here in saving the earth by constantly
using plastic grocery bags so we got to
move on to 2020 which it won't matter if
we save the planet anyway because our
country is going to be in ashes if the
Democrats win Joe Biden has released his
first TV ad and you could not have
possibly scripted this ad any better Joe
Biden the 76 year old daughter in
candidate in the race who can't even
remember his own URL for his campaign
website
he has titled his first TV ad bones take
a listen
we know in our bones this election is
different stop it right there
we know we know in our bones we feel it
in our bones that this election is
different I feel it in my bones because
I don't have anything else to feel I'm
Joe Biden a bag of bones vote for me to
be your president I'm a skeleton Joe
Biden really leaning in to the age issue
it's like the classic thing with Biden
he can't help but put his foot in his
mouth I mean even this who cares right I
mean he's he's an old guy but just you
know if you're writing this if it's
going through all the different stages
of production post-production it's being
released this is your first television
ad like don't call it bone don't don't
call it bones don't use bones as the
frigate just reminds people that you are
thousand years old okay continue the
stakes are higher the threat more
serious we have to be Donald Trump and
all the polls agreed Joe Biden is the
strongest Democrat to do the job no one
is more qualified for eight years
President Obama and Vice President Biden
where an administration America can be
proud of our allies could trust and our
kids could look up to
together they work to save the American
economy to pass the historic Affordable
Care Act protecting over 100 million
Americans with pre-existing conditions
now Joe Biden is running for president
with the plan for America's future to
build on Obamacare not scrap it to make
a record investment in America's schools
to lead the world on climate to rebuild
our alliances most of all and restore
the soul of the nation battered by an
erratic vicious bullying precedent
strong steady stable leadership Biden
president I'm Joe Biden and I approve
this message okay let's break this down
cuz it's not a great ad but I think it's
signaling that the Biden campaign is
moving closer to the right direction
there are four parts to this ad at the
other than him talking about how he
feels
aches in his bones like osteoarthritis
or whatever he feels the first part is
that Trump is a racist so this is how he
launched his presidential campaign the
first lines out of his mouth in his
announcement video were perpetuating
that charlottesville hoax the president
Trump called neo-nazis and white
supremacists very fine people even
though you can see in the video footage
Trump explicitly condemns the neo-nazis
and the white supremacists that was the
pitch from the beginning Trump is a
racist vote for me and he's keeping this
up here you see the images from
Charlottesville and the tiki torches and
the white supremacists saying Trump is a
racist all right the next part of the ad
is Biden is the most electable this is
the probably the weakest part of the
whole ad in terms of the Democratic
electorate they already got burned on
this argument Hillary's argument in 2016
was vote for Hillary Hillary is the
most electable don't vote for Bernie
Sanders don't vote for that other guy
who played guitar on the view what was
his name Martin O'Malley don't vote for
anyone else
I mean don't vote for any of the other
candidates who wanted to get into the
race but didn't because Hillary was the
inevitable electable candidate actually
including Joe Biden don't do that
Hillary is the most electable and then
guess what she didn't get elected so I
don't think the electability argument is
really gonna work this was the argument
for John Kerry in 2004 vote for John
Kerry he's moderate he's normal he's the
most electable guess what he didn't get
elected actually one of the arguments
against Barack Obama in 2008 and for
Hillary Clinton was Hillary is the
electable candidate and America's never
gonna elect a guy named Barack Hussein
Obama to be the president even forget
the issue of race even just his name
sounds so foreign Mnet's we obviously
were just fighting a war against a man
named Saddam Hussein it ain't gonna work
don't vote for him he's not electable
and then what happened he did get
elected because he actually offered a
vision it was a pretty vague vision was
a pretty leftist vision but he offered
something that Hillary Clinton did not
and Joe Biden is falling into this trap
of just vote for me I'm the most
electable you're only the most electable
if you get elected buddy and Joe Biden's
poll numbers are still strong he's still
leading the pack but just barely one
poll has him tied with Elizabeth Warren
at this point statistically and he keeps
dropping as other candidates keep rising
so that that's pretty weak then the
third part of his ad is pretty good
which is he's tying himself to Obama
it's a tough play because Obama is sort
of passe now in the Democratic Party but
if Obama comes out and endorses by then
that would be a huge help to Biden Obama
hasn't done it yet but Biden should keep
sucking up and try to get him to do it
Michelle Obama is very popular at this
point she might be more popular than her
husband she had that best-selling book
the Democrats love her if he could try
to get her support that would be very
helpful tying him himself to Obama's
legacies is probably a good idea in any
circumstance but it's especially an
important idea in this circumstance
because what else does he have he's been
in politics for 50 years he didn't
accomplish anything in the Senate other
than hold up the Clarence Thomas
hearings in 1991 and pass a crime bill
in 1994
a very good crime bill but he's got to
run away from that aspect of his career
now because the Democrats are going soft
on crime and law enforcement so the only
thing he's got is that he was the vice
president to a relatively popular
president named Barack Obama tying him
that's a that's a good point then he
closes the add-on Trump is a jerk
basically Trump's a terrible guy and I'm
gonna restore the soul of this nation
Biden is as vacillated in this campaign
between being the moderate candidate in
the Democratic Party I say moderate only
relatively he's still a pretty left-wing
guy but compared to I don't know beta or
or core Kamala Harris or Elizabeth
Warren he's pretty moderate he's
vacillated between that and the end
between being the horror left radical
saying he no longer supports the Hyde
Amendment he he now supports taxpayer
funding for abortion all he's trying to
veer to the left he's not gonna win that
way he's not gonna win by being somebody
other than Joe Biden so I think if he
doubles down on this
I'm the legacy of Obama I'm going to
continue the Oh the Obama era I'm going
to bring us all back to that good era
before that awful mean old orange man
the mango Mussolini came in and made
everybody angry that could go somewhere
but he just keeps putting his foot in
his mouth I'm not convinced that that
this is gonna be enough even just the
way the ad is made it's like old TV it
looks like it's from two campaign cycles
ago meanwhile you give a president Trump
who is the king of social media he's
always ahead on the media he's a king of
the media and a creation of the media I
mean he's he's kept himself in the
headlines for 40 years at this point
someone who's going to use the same old
tired traditional media strategies even
if he makes it through the primary
election probably not going to have an
easy time in the general we have got to
get to my favorite news story of the
entire day which is about your precious
bodily fluids it's about a conspiracy
theory from all those far-right Kooks
that has gone on for 50 years more than
that 75 years at this point and everyone
discredited it and then it turns out a
study shows it might have been true
we'll get
that at the end of the show I've got to
bring on my friend Matt bass who's here
and I've got to say goodbye to Facebook
in YouTube you are almost out of time to
purchase tickets to our backstage live
show tomorrow night August 21st at the
incredible Terrace theater in Long Beach
California we don't do a lot of these
shows this is gonna be the only one this
year it's going to be an incredible
amount of fun Ben Shapiro daily wire
guide King Jeremy boring Andrew Clavin
and most importantly me we will be
talking politics and pop culture best of
all we'll be answering your questions
from the audience
I love these events you know again we
don't do a ton of them but when we have
done them they're so fun it's so great
to get to talk to everybody tickets are
available at daily wire.com slash
backstage there is still a few VIP
ticket packages available which include
premium seating photos and meet and
greets with each of us a gift from mr.
Shapiro and more they're almost gone so
head on over to daily wired.com slash
backstage and get yours today go to
daily wire we'll be right back with a
lot more
we got to get to my friend Matt best
Matt best you probably know him as one
of the guys over at black rifle coffee
company matt has an incredible story he
joined the army at age 17 he deployed
five times to Iraq and Afghanistan with
the 2nd Ranger Battalion 75th Ranger
Regiment pretty tough guy you know after
he left the military he then worked as a
contractor with the CIA for five years
then he gets his bachelor's degree and
he starts creating satirical videos he
gets very involved in the media he helps
build brands like article 15 clothing to
the drinking Burroughs podcast and then
as you would all know a company that I
love black rifle coffee so he's got a
new book out and it's got a hilarious
title thank you for my service Matt came
by and we were able to chat for a few
minutes while he was going through LA so
without further ado Matt best Matt
thanks for being here thank you so much
for having me on I'm excited by the way
Matt with a name like Matt best you
pretty much have to run for Senate don't
you yeah there's a lot to live up to
especially with one tea it's a little
awkward but that's true yeah yeah my
parents set me up to hopefully do
something great that's it really well
you have you already have done something
great you've got a very hilariously
named title for your book
thank you for my service indeed and this
this book covers a lot I think a lot
that people would be interested in I
know people are interested in you
because of your coffee I know that for a
fact that my listeners are interested in
that but also it you know it occurs to
me something like 1% of Americans serve
in the military at this point yep you
know I I have a lot of military members
in my family so I kind of lose sight of
that the majority of Americans probably
have little to no contact with anybody
who's actually served in the armed
forces that's fair to say and that's
really the whole reason I wanted to
write this book to kind of discuss the
internal workings of being in Special
Operations and loving my job I think too
often people that don't understand the
veteran community penas is kind of
depressive failures and victims I think
we're the complete antithesis of that I
think that we're successful and
motivated and kinda wanted to combine
that all and so one crazy package and
then tell us
on war stories I've had some veteran
pals of mine have said this they say one
of the big issues in our current culture
which basically rewards victimhood yep
you know this leftist kind of if you can
claim victimhood you get special
privileges that in some ways it's
actually turned military veterans who
should be the most heroic the most
honored you know in our in our society
they've turned them into a special
victim class - absolutely I mean if you
look at any Hollywood movie out there
it's the veteran comes back from war his
puppy dies he gets addicted to different
you know the press of medication
whatever the case self-medication and
you know while there are issues about
people coming back from war that need to
be addressed I think the larger part of
the veteran community that comes back is
motivated and successful and I really
want to change that narrative in
Hollywood and just in civilian culture
is also so what do you think the biggest
misconceptions are obviously this idea
is that military victims exactly instead
I think when people they don't know if
they say thank you for your service but
you know when I come back and someone
finds out at five deployments in a
ranger baton it's almost like I can't
imagine what you've seen you know I
signed up for that job to go participate
in the defense of America and willingly
and knowingly go take care of bad guys
that want to kill innocent Americans so
I'm just thankful for the opportunity to
go serve my country and I want people to
know that there's guys and gals out
there just like that and you also when
you came back you've had an incredibly
successful career as a civilian yes I
got out and you know went through a
couple transition things and then I went
as a contractor for five years so I
spent almost three years plus on the
ground within that capacity which I
learned a lot from there and then that
transitioned into entrepreneurship and
trying to create something special what
about your military service do you think
translated to the business side is that
because we here you know veterans are
the guest workers obviously they're very
disciplined obviously they're very
courageous is that overblown or do you
think that your experience in the
military really has helped you as an
entrepreneur 100% you know I think
something especially in Special
Operations community is creative
problem-solving so looking at a very
complex problem and then activating the
team to navigate that and I think that's
what business is you're presented
with all these challenges every day the
stress is immense but you have to rally
that team and solve the problems and
keep moving forward and it's a reason
why we hire so many veterans of black
rifle coffee for that sole reason is
they have such a diverse set of skills
that honestly I don't know where else
you'd find someone with that other than
the veteran community and you know it's
funny because you you do stand out a
little bit to me and that a lot of my
veteran friends are there not very
verbose they're not very loquacious
they're men of few words and you're kind
of like a triple threat I mean obviously
you've got this service physically
you're like pretty tough guy wouldn't
want to meet you in a back alley
anywhere you also have this business
acumen this business brain but you're
also good on camera I mean you've also
been able to really master this moment
in social media use that to help your
business use that to obviously
communicate through your book are you
unique in that regard I mean how did you
develop those skills
I don't think so I've just activated on
those skills you know again I don't
think that being a veteran should define
you for the whole rest of your life it's
merely a guideline of Who I am today and
I've always loved art and being a
creator and an ideator and so given the
opportunity post-military I kind of took
all my experiences and you started
youtube videos to make people laugh and
engage my community and I think that's
what's most important about telling this
story is whether you're into artistry or
drawing or making cups mugs whatever you
want to chase in life you can do it and
don't let anybody restrict you from
doing that one thing I love about black
rifle coffee actually my favorite thing
about black coffee is it's very good
tasting coffee this is the thing I don't
care how many veterans you employ it's
not good tasting coffee maybe I'll buy
it but I'll probably just throw it out I
love that it's great tasting coffee how
did you develop that expertise where
does that come from why the passion for
coffee really I'm a marketing and
branding guy and so when I co-founded it
with Evan hey for the CEO former Green
Beret
she used the roast coffee overseas in
Iraq and during the invasion and as a
CIA contractor so he really had this
massive passion for coffee because it's
so communal every morning the team guys
would come in showed that cup of coffee
talk about the operation and then go
execute on it
and so that's really why we call it a
black rifle it's a tribute to military
service and Brotherhood and obviously
Evan is a coffee nerd so it's gonna be
the best tasting coffee out there but
you know my second favorite thing about
black rifle obviously the first most
important it's got to be good coffee
second is it doesn't hate American so I
go you know I go to these other coffee
shops and I I feel they're a little
unpatriotic I feel they're a little
they're donating to things that I hate
they're doing any things that seem
anti-american and we haven't at this
moment an actual epidemic of anti
Americanism people protesting the
American flag Betsy Ross is apparently
now some kind of bigot you've got major
politicians running for president
Democratic politicians who are
applauding those who would denigrate our
flag does this anti Americanism does
this worry you in the long term I do you
think it's just some short rated that
the whole reason why we exist because
I'm not gonna play Kate the PC culture
we're gonna be exactly who we are mark
twain's something said to the effect of
being a patriot is loving your country
all the time and your government when it
deserves it and America stands for unity
and and just absolute love I love this
country so much we do so many amazing
things and you know I will say something
about other corporate entities when a
law enforcement officers ask to leave my
coffee shop the person that asked that
will be escorted out and the law
enforcement will be given a free cup of
coffee I can't stand for that it's
actually it's absolutely atrocious that
we're treating civil servants and
veterans this way it's it's got to
change and if not I got to do it right
and by the way you know one of the lines
that we keep pointing out is get woke go
broke so there's this very small group
of leftist agitators who wants to tear
down the whole country basically and
they want to protest the flag and
generally speaking when companies cater
to them their profits decline their
customer base declines they start to go
out of business because they're probably
not working so that's right good very
hard at yeah but then you know your
company is kind of just the proof of
this is you go out there and you say
look guys you can get coffee at a
million different places yeah here's a
cup of coffee
that doesn't hate America and all of a
sudden you become one of the biggest
coffee companies in the world yeah I
think there's a sense of irreverence and
passion for America and we always say
vote with your dollar and I think so
that we do well is we're a very
transparent company in what we do we
show where we donate our funds to who
we're supporting and if you like us you
can buy it if you don't well then do it
do something else
that's right it's a vote with your
dollar it's it's it's very hard in 2019
to be transparent with a corporate
entity and know what they're actually
giving you know other people say support
veterans but they're throwing money that
absolutely doesn't support a bachelor
and one thing you know I also like that
you guys have a sense of humor I find
politics these days so everyone takes
themselves so seriously but you you guys
have a real sense of humor you really
embrace the love of country with some
levity to it too you know I mean you've
got like the the Benjamin Franklin yeah
you know like join or die right on the
on the mug I find a lot of that kind of
comedy in the book I mean I think a lot
of military books also are a little
drier I don't want to be on charitable
but they're a little drier your book is
not dry yeah I believe you know kind of
humor through horror and all the
experiences that I've had in my life and
I their people have done extraordinarily
more amounts of stuff in the military
than me but you kind of got a laugh is
this there's no dress rehearsal in life
and so if you're not smiling and loving
and creating community and I even here
right and when does the book come out
oddest 20th August 20th so it's coming
up but you're probably on a media blitz
right now I was excited to be here so
Trey that's right you know excited to be
here and I figure like first of all
compared to like Ramadi this isn't that
bad and also compared to you know
compared to fighting overseas probably a
media blitz you can handle yeah it's
done something like that before all
right I can't wait to I can't wait to
hear back from everyone else listening
on what they think of the book I know
what they think of the coffee and they
love it Matt thank you for being here
thank you for your service and in terms
of my day to day probably the most
important
thank you for your coffee oh thank you
yeah three of those and for my service
and everything here and having me on the
show all right Matt good to see it
Cheers
all right now we've got to talk about
something much more important than any
of this which is how we are all Alex
Jones now we're all Alex Jeff this is
more important than the environmental
protection this is more important than
even Matt's book even though it's a very
good book and I highly recommend you buy
it this is
more important than the 2020 election
it's the fact that nobody knows anything
nobody knows anything things we've been
told for fifty years a hundred years
they can be upended overnight the food
pyramid we were told there's the food
pyramid you got to eat a ton of carbs
and not a lot of fat now the food
pyramid is exactly the opposite
conspiracy theories are popping up and
apparently true overnight one of them is
one of the oldest ones in the book truly
proof that nobody knows anything for
decades the kookiest crankiest wackiest
conspiracy theorists on the right have
harped on one conspiracy theory above
almost all the others that the fluoride
that the government puts in drinking
water is harmful to us this began in
1945 the US began fluoridating water
because it prevents tooth decay and the
caricature that almost immediately
developed of right-wingers was that they
all thought that this was a communist
plot to destroy us and the fluoride in
the water was messing with our brains
and and affecting us somehow this was
parodied in the great film dr.
Strangelove when the Brigadier General
Jack D Ripper
talks about our precious bodily fluids I
can no longer sit back and allow
communist infiltration communist
indoctrination communist subversion now
that part we all agree with I mean
that's just that's not the conspiracy
theory part but then this is where the
caricature comes in and the
International communist conspiracy to
SAP and and purify all of our precious
bodily fluids ok ha ha ha you crazy
stupid right-wingers ha ha ha you guys
are so dumb right well it turns out the
conspiracy theorists very likely have a
point there is a new study out published
in an influential medical journal that
links fluoride consumption during
pregnancy with lower childhood IQs
apparently the fluoride in the drinking
water according to this study is so
affecting our precious bodily fluids
that it's making us
stupider to put this into perspective
3/4 of the United States drinks
fluoridated tap water and now when I'm
at the San Francisco Airport I can't
even buy a regular water bottle without
any fluoride in it because that's been
banned so I have to bring my own water
bottle and fill up the fluoridated tap
water oh my gosh maybe this is all of
the conspiracies are just coming
together right now the main takeaway
from this is not necessarily that
communist infiltration is affecting our
precious bodily fluids
yes it could be but the main takeaway is
that we know much much less about the
material world than we think that we do
we know so much less we pass these
environmental regulations all these big
policies because we say this is how
we're gonna help the environment and
guess what we do because we're so stupid
we end up harming the environment with
the very policies that were intended to
help the environment we tell everybody
you've got to eat the food pyramid
you've got to stuff your face with
cereal and pasta and breads that's how
you're gonna be healthy and then 50
years later they tell you actually
whether we got it a little bit wrong you
actually shouldn't have any of those
things at all ever but you should eat a
lot of fat and I don't know what it's
gonna be tomorrow one day we find out
coffee is really healthy for you the
next day we find out coffee is really
bad for you then the next day is really
healthy for you again the eggs are
really good for you then eggs are really
bad for you then eggs are really good
for you again
global warming is guaranteed going to
flood New York by 2013 or 2015 or
actually never but it'll you know maybe
in a little bit but we're not quite sure
when the earth is going to end in ten
months twelve months 14 months 35 years
12 years 14 years I don't know but it's
going to end soon we know much much less
about the material world then we think
that we do what this calls for my humble
suggestion is a little humility it's a
little humility in your politics
maybe not passing these sweeping
gigantic major governmental changes
giving the government huge amounts of
power on dubious
premises maybe being a little cautious
maybe looking for a little bit of
evolution rather than revolution in our
politics and our culture a little bit of
humility and yet we live in a culture
right now that celebrates pride we have
whole months where we celebrate pride
not very promising this is true not just
in our precious bodily fluids in our tap
water not just in environmental
regulations but in everything else to
healthcare foreign policy the economy a
little humility goes a long way but how
can you ever recapture humility in a
culture that celebrates pride that's our
problem we'll have to figure it out but
we won't be able to figure it out today
because we're at a time I will see those
of you who are gonna be at Long Beach
tomorrow live at our daily wire
backstage live event no show tomorrow
we'll be back on Thursday and do a
Friday show in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
see you soon
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy bori our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Danny D'Amico our audio mixer is
Mike Cora Meena hair and makeup by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth if
you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on into the Ben Shapiro show or
they'll get a whole lot of that and much
more we'll see you there
you